the big name fans of course is fan art
and sarahpascoe
I know you have had that accolade of
people sending you fan art good
so I've got one piece and I think fan
art is a strong word yes it's of me
actually it's worth saying that it's all
of you this is the fan art of surpasses
time is I was given this as a gig in
lieu of payment that's because the guy
who ran the geek had spent too much at
the bar to pay me so he paid it back yes
after being at the bar what are those
bits I just think they're just free
biscuits pictures of people who care
tune your face on their back no I'm not
there yet get them in my Twitter feed
all the terms gather the whole care of
the cares or a picture of jewels on
their chests or Wow Nick Fury Tommy
Wilson you have fan offered such
specific fan art this is a lot yeah does
it all come for this one scene it was at
the first Thor movie with the spirit
right yeah yes there's that there's a
scene in a first thought um where my I'm
trying to attack Thor Chris Hemsworth as
Thor with this spear and jump in the air
and he duck he dodges out the way and I
bring the spear down and it wedges
itself into the floor and then I Lee
used the user to spin myself around and
kick him in the chest
which has been interpreted by fans as a
demonstration of my hidden talent at
pole down old death
yeah yeah no I see there's so much of
this but this is just one example of
Loki really going for it on the pole
is that Japanese seen it
yeah that's Toby's outfit yeah I've not
seen that one but really we'll print it
out you can take it
and you're just watching Sam it's really
powerful you go hang on a second what's
my line we must ask you James Bond Tom
Hiddleston what's the scoop what's going
on